-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well.
And now if you don't mind,
we're going to get to the news.
President Biden celebrated
his 80th birthday yesterday
with a brunch hosted by
First Lady Dr. Jill Biden.
Brunch, or as 80-year-olds
call it, dinner.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden today pardoned
the national Thanksgiving
turkey,
but I don't know if this is one
we want back on the streets.
[ Laughter ]
That's right.
President Biden today pardoned
the national Thanksgiving
turkeys, Chocolate and Chip.
And then this is weird.
He sent the green bean casserole
to Gitmo.
[ Laughter ]
RNC chairwoman Ronna McDaniel
reportedly told top Republican
donors last week that the party
needs to avoid
factionalism and unify
like a family.
Ah, yes, spoken like a person
who's never been in a family.
[ Laughter ]
After missing eight games, the
Brooklyn Nets yesterday allowed
Kyrie Irving to return
to the team after
apologizing for posting a link
to an anti-Semitic documentary.
It's a miracle.
His suspension was only supposed
to last for one game,
but it lasted eight.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden over the weekend
called the U.S. soccer men's
national team and gave them
a pep talk
ahead of the World Cup.
I'm not sure if it worked,
but they were definitely late
for the game.
[ Laughter ]
NASA's Orion capsule today
passed the moon and flew around
its backside, and scientists
were shocked by
what they found
on the other side.
[ Laughter ]
We're taking submissions
from second graders this week.
[ Laughter ]
A book was recently returned to
a library in Minnesota
after being overdue
for nearly 50 years.
The book was titled
"How to Stop Procrastinating."
[ Laughter ]
The book is so old,
that joke was in it.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, Amtrak next month
will expand service
between New York City
and Albany.
"Hell yeah!" said Albany.
And "we're good!"
said New York City.
[ Laughter ]
That was a monologue, everybody.